what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time while
while she's trying to get rich russell's
trying to get her lunch money right i'm
here with the beautiful intelligent
pelina eva lova marinova pompeono
p-i-m-p
she's got some iso i got cheetahs on my
shirt today
okay don't forget that block fly is now
the sponsor of lunch money you can go to
blockbuy.com and open up an account
which means you can earn up to eight
point six percent apy in an
interest-bearing account
you can buy and sell crypto with no fees
or you can deposit crypto and take out a
us dollar loan to get your crypto
collateral
and if you have an account you can get a
list for the bitcoin rewards credit card
that is coming it's a credit card that
pays you bitcoin back
rather than cash back go get a block
five count block fight.com
what's up what is up is happy 50k
day i'm not even excited what
psych told y'all
so listen bitcoin surpassed 50 000 for
the first time ever
as large firms like tesla mastercard and
bny
melon have shown support for
cryptocurrencies in retrospect
it was inevitable that's all you have to
remember
i've been saying it and saying it insane
what does this mean for years
what does that mean you have a fixed
supply asset
if demand goes up one thing happens
which is the
price in u.s dollar terms of that asset
has to go
up now the big question is for sure
we know it's a fix supply asset so will
demand go up or not
well people are waking up to the fact
that this asset
is a pretty good store of value it's
better than gold
it's better than real estate it's better
than any analog
asset it is the greatest digital
store of value and therefore people are
saying
i want that and when they show up to the
market and they say i have
500 million dollars i want that
bitcoiners say
i'm not selling you that and when
bitcoiners say i'm not selling you that
at ten thousand dollars then the people
who showed up say
okay but i wanted that fifteen thousand
and then the bitcoiners said
but i'm not gonna sell it to you for 15.
and then the new people say
what about 20 or 25 or 30 or 40
or 50 000 and the bitcoiners keep saying
i'm not going to sell it to you at that
because 60
of the bitcoin hasn't moved in the last
12 months even though there's been
hundreds of percent of appreciation
and even days where it dropped 50 in a
single day
this thing is like a bronco or a bull
when you get in the seat
wrap your hand around it and don't let
go
that's what holders are doing that's
what the market is doing
and i ain't selling my bitcoin to wall
street you all do whatever you want but
they ain't getting mine
no way guys last night last night felt
like new year's eve he was screaming
i was like screaming i played music i
played music
and when we got close to 50k i did say
you screamed i i did yell one time to
plana
joking i said man your battle stations
and i
started playing music and sat down in
this exact seat
and manned my battle station and waited
i had a meeting
memes were locked and loaded ready to
roll all right let's get ready
yes so disk space is almost
full retailers restaurants and other
business owners are opening up around
palm beach florida eyeing tax and
lifestyle perks
as more people look to call south
florida home during the pandemic and
beyond
retail rents are rising in the palm
beach area sign that
demand for space is picking up and
supply is more constrained
than in places like new york city stop
spending i'm gonna call i'm gonna call
it right now miami's gonna turn into the
next new york
you think it's already an international
city in the sense of it's kind of the
gateway to
uh south and central america it's
already got an international airport
tourists come like it's got a lot of
these the same elements
but absolutely what i mean is from an
infrastructure standpoint is nowhere
nearly as developed as new york city is
uh in terms of the high rises and the
density uh per square foot can we go see
per square mile and so i think that
that's drastically going to change in uh
in the coming years just given the
influx of people
the influx of capital and the influx of
attention that's going on
there's outdoor shopping malls popping
up like
yeah they're gonna develop all this
stuff there's too many people moving
here not enough infrastructure
which is similar to bitcoin but we still
don't know if the people moving here is
a fad
or if it's long term well if you buy a
house you're probably staying hey
i mean okay a lot of people aren't
buying houses right just get me to the
story i want to talk about
all right we've been sitting on this one
for a while because i know my friend
here has opinions but it's time to talk
about it
now democrats are slamming lying
andrew cuomo over kovac 19 nursing home
cover-up the man has been covering up
data and yes if you go back into the
archives of lunch money you will see
him saying there will be an
investigation cuomo will be charged as
he's
whatever and i was like okay let's calm
down i don't think that's gonna happen
somehow it's happening and so i told
y'all
go get the receipts somebody go find the
freaking receipts
i told y'all this dude is a coward
he's an idiot he's corrupt
and now the best part is he allegedly
is a criminal he is literally a criminal
and when i said
when i said it back in the day whatever
last year
i said his decision-making
is leading to death and therefore
you should not be immune to punishment
the same way that a private citizen this
is
the worst attack on american citizens
but on a per-death basis of anything
that's happened in the u.s in the last
20 years
this man's decisions his sole decisions
he went against
what the organization said he went
against what the
nursing homes wanted to do the nursing
homes literally said
we believe that it is a bad idea to take
people with covet
and put them into our nursing home where
society's most vulnerable people are
and he said no you have to do it he
mandated that they did it
and he did it all as a cowardly
[Music]
virtue signal to say that oh it's free
uh
free health care for everybody or equal
health care for everybody what pisses me
off the most
is this was a holic political theater he
played with people's lives
and and he wrote a book
about his leadership during that time
and
recorded the audiobook all right i
listen i'm gonna say this one time all
right and y'all gonna put this
here if andrew cuomo
is not treated like a criminal
if he is found to have done the things
that he has
allegedly done which is he made
decisions
that led to that led to eight figures
we're talking more than 10 000 people
died
directly attributable to his decision
making
and then while he knew it was going on
he hid the data him and his team talked
about it and hid the data to prevent
people from knowing it was happening
if we do not treat him like a criminal
if he is found guilty of doing this
if we do not treat him like a criminal
we are no different than
iran north korea china or anywhere else
where we allow corruption to just
persist out in the open
this is the definition of
corruption you literally did something
that got people killed they died
more than 10 000 people died so
and then you hit the data that is the
lowest
scummiest most coward [ __ ] i ever heard
and those are the types of people who
end up trying to ascend in politics
and we should do every single thing in
our power to not only prevent them from
having political aspirations
but they should go to [ __ ] jail
that's what should happen
because you killed people and you should
go to jail
if that is what you did so again it's
allegations at the moment
i've been saying it now for over a year
is that what is happening or
almost a year whatever it's been what is
happening
is poor leadership that because they are
arrogant
and they're egotistical they decided
they were gonna virtue signal they're
gonna hold their stupid press
conferences every day
and in fact they actually ended up
hurting their citizens more than helping
them
and we must we must hold these people
accountable if you don't
you're no different than any other
corrupt country that allows their
leaders to do dumb
and not hold them accountable that's all
i gotta say
and during a press conference cuomo was
asked if he wanted to apologize
for hiding the data and making decisions
that led to deaths
and he was like apologize he's like i'm
you know
i take responsibility for people not
understanding that the decisions that i
made like
what and so fellow democratic
legislators in new york weren't buying
his explanation as to why he refused for
months to release a true accounting
of nursing home residents who died from
the coronavirus
uh assemblyman ron kim uh whose uncle
died from covet bluntly said that all of
it
is bs and a cover-up that is
wild i mean we've made like society
and and the justice system has made
examples of people who have done
far less than this if they truly don't
charge them with something i i'd be
shocked just because the criminal wears
cologne doesn't mean that they get off
and suits and ties by the way
everything that i have said here is an
allegation and may be proven
inaccurate so do not take my word for
accuracy instead we should allow the
court of law every single person has
their day in court and he will allow
uh have an opportunity to present his
case but we must
have the day in court because this is
absurd wait guys
there's two people i don't like bullies
and hypocrites
he is kind of both of those to me in my
opinion okay
ready oh this is a wild story
an invitation from elon musk for russian
president vladimir putin
to join him for a chat on a social
networking app
called clubhouse the kremlin responded
and said very interesting
very interesting musk tagged the
kremlin's twitter account tweeting
would you like to join me for a
conversation on clubhouse
and it would be great honor to speak
with you and
chris the kremlin spokesman on a
conference called a reporter said in
general this is of course
a very interesting proposal but we need
to understand what is meant
what is being proposed first we need to
check then we will react
this episode of lunch money is going to
be called corruption edition
listen if elon musk gets
if he gets vladimir what is he on
clubhouse what is the point of this i
mean
who knows what they want to talk about
but that would be all time
elon musk is already in the hall of fame
of internet memes and trolls
if he pulls this off he he is not in
just in the hall of fame
he's an untouchable he's an immortal in
the internet hall of fame
keep in mind keep in mind that putin has
previously described the internet as a
cia
project and has styled himself as
suspicious
of modern technology if he thinks that
the internet is a cia project
that he does not like i am not sure he
will like clubhouse
but we'll see internet hall of fame
that's that's what this moment was the
2020s are so
wild so far oh 2020s 2020s are so
wilderness
making dumb decisions we have dictators
showing up on clubhouse
global pandemics okay
okay a tennessee man passed away
and he uh and he'll in his
will left five million dollars
to his dog lulu an eight-year-old border
collie
wow so martha burton lulu's caretaker
now told
the station lulu's owner bill doris was
a successful businessman who wasn't
married and died last year
his will states that the money should be
put into a trust for lulu's care
it allows for burn to be reimbursed for
reasonable monthly expenses in the care
of lulu
what do you think about this millionaire
dog multi-million
dollars you better get lulu's uh net
worth correct
to i think lulu should buy bitcoin wait
right
so the the current uh caretaker says
said
he just really loved the dog she says
she doesn't know if she could ever
spend five million dollars on lulu but
she says
well i'd like to can you imagine being a
dog and
like having like a normal life and then
all of a sudden one day you're like damn
there's a lot of bones around here
damn i got a lot of toys damn i got a
nice ass dog
house good for this damn some plush ass
carpet i'm laying my little head on
like can you imagine what dog life would
you live with five million dollars i
would be the most lavish dog
lavish dog lavish i'd be vibing y'all
could check me on the gram
i would be out here literally if i was
that dog i'd be like you better get me
right here you better put that little
little crown on my head all right he'd
be having dog photo shoots
five million dollars i have a
professional photographer follow me
around for 10 years
all right i'll be the most famous dog in
the world oh my god
so i'd be like oh can you please get me
some great poupon
with my dog food thank you very much oh
i think i need a vegetarian chef no you
like me as a dog
oh i think i need a carnivore chef then
i think that i need to
understand no more the kibbles and bits
nope
i want steak if i ain't getting steak
then
you're fired and i got five million
dollars and you don't
you'd be the worst millionaire dog and
the best part is the only way that you
can
communicate all that is
are you enjoying yourself yeah i'm
having a blood okay
moist update so i don't know how we're
handling moist because yesterday was a
holiday we didn't publish lunch money
and then friday i don't think we
published lunch did moy's
is moist moist i need to know are you a
man or a woman or unidentified sex
he gave you a fun fact all right okay
it's so he okay first of all moy says
day four of commenting on every episode
lunch money until pop gives me an
interview i didn't promise an internship
i set a call
but go ahead but then he he shot his
shot
and he said i know you're a busy man but
what's the possibility that 96 days we
can turn this phone call to a
face-to-face conversation
all right i just so happen to be based
in the triangle area and i'm also sure
you would agree that a face-to-face
first impression
has much more value and potential upside
compared to a virtual first impression
no sweat for now i still have 86 days to
convince you just wanted to go ahead and
infect your mind with the possibility
hashtag moist gang hashtag and reach the
moisture
unleashing moisture what what do you
think about that before we get to the
fun fact he's a 20 year old male
i just i first heard about crypto from a
guy that was selling me weed and i
legalized it yeah moist we might get
along
okay so hashtag moist gang legalize weed
you you heard about uh bitcoin from your
weed dealer
this is this is a wild guy i need
another question i need another answer
here
well what do you i want to know what
profession you engage in on a daily
basis
don't tell me where you look don't tell
me the name of the couple 20 years old
he might still be in school
okay well then that your then your
profession or your occupation
is student that's what i need to know
what is your profession we're going to
do
we're going to do a live this is like
the 90-day
job interview right now that's what
we're about to do all right so the next
fun fact moist
is what what is your oculus
ask lunch money love the show i watch
every day
you said you have multiple people
working with you that you've never met
in person
what's your advice for building and
leading a team to help with your
business and take it to the next level
i hire freelancers on places like upwork
but i usually don't get the results i'm
looking for
or spend lots of time editing their work
you know what i do
i do the exact opposite what everyone
tells you to do what do you mean
i hire people full time i pay them well
i give them upside and on top of all of
that
i make sure that they know that
it's their work so when guys on our team
send me memes i tag them on twitter i
want them to
succeed and i think that where it all
starts is there's a bunch of execution
stuff blocking and tackling at the end
of the day
it just comes down to you really have to
want to see the people you work with
succeed
i would rather me succeed a little
and them succeed yep quite a bit then
have me succeed a lot and then not
succeed but alex is
asking okay but like how how do i do how
do i build a team and take it to the
next level
assume he can't hire like three people
you don't have to hire three people
but if you're hiring freelancers stop
hiring the freelancers get somebody who
is your person like stop using these
websites find a good person
and just one person and just one person
pay them well
get give them some upside like get them
bought in right
it's incentives drive the world if you
align incentives
everyone goes in the same direction and
the truth is
even if you don't have enough you're not
making enough money right now to pay
somebody a
full annual salary you could do a
structure where they get more upside
than cash right there's i'll give you a
perfect example there's somebody
who works with me uh on something that
most of you don't know about
and uh i said to them uh i'll pay you
some cash and then a little bit of
upside upside being like
revenue a revenue share and the person
responded to me and they said i don't
want any cash i just want upside
because it aligns incentives if he does
a good job he'll get a ton more money
than just an annual salary no you know
what i said
okay fine deal i'll give you more upside
than i was originally
thinking why because that's the exact
type of person you want to work with you
want to work with somebody who wants the
upside
so i think that's the the key here waldo
mcp
mcpherson has a question for you is the
goal of bitcoin to ultimately gain the
trust of merchants
the commercial world or everyday and
everyday people or is it to gain the
trust of the fed and regulators or is it
a combination of both more so
one or the other he didn't hear my
questions
reading the question go gain the trust
of merchants the commercial world and
everyday people or is it to get interest
of the fed and the regulators
the only people that matter are the
average person
that's it why the regulators can't do
anything
if it's adopted by everybody in their
country
it's it's game over checkmate like game
set match
checkmate people know that it has value
people believe in it and the narrative
has taken over
checkmate it has to be adopted now
and so therefore everyone is going to
capitulate thank you guys if you have a
question for us
put it in the comments below with the
hashtag asklm
i would apologize for my rant earlier
but i ain't apologizing for things that
i said were gonna happen
that i knew were happening and people
laughed at me
and now this clown's out here not
apologizing as well
yeah fool that's what he is he's silly
he's a fool
all right see ya bang bang
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block 5
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange i personally
use the interest bearing account
there's not very many places where
you'll find up to 8.6
interest on a deposit in an interest
bearing account go do your own research
there's risk associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfy
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends